okay we're ready to begin again we're
running late so let's just start as
quickly as possible this section on
groups and individuals in fairness
we'll begin with Cynthia dork
so this is very much work in progress in
April I stood up here and I gave a talk
with the same starting slide but there
has been progress made it's good to know
okay great so you've heard a lot in the
last couple of days about individualist
versus groups versus structures and so
on in the literature on the theory of
algorithmic fairness there are two broad
categories of definitions one is indeed
very broad and that's the category of
group fairness definitions and then
there's a smaller category of individual
fairness so group fairness examples from
the computer science literature would be
something like this a statistical parity
or demographic parity it says let's say
if you're looking at college admissions
that the demographics of students that
are accepted to your college are the
same as the demographics of the
population as a whole and another
example might be balance for the
positive class among those with credit
scores above some threshold value T the
probability of receiving a loan is the
same for the members of the minority
group as for members of the majority
group so among qualified candidates for
the loan the probability should be the
same so there are many ways this is a
very reductive statement but basically
there are many ways in which group
notions fail and so here are a few
examples
statistical parity might sound nice but
you can twist things so for those of you
who were here when Evelyn Hammonds asked
what do dia reticle computer scientists
do and I said well we think about these
problems from an adversary
aerial perspective and we tried to
imagine an adversary who is as nasty and
twisty and devious as possible and and
we see what are the goals of this
horrible adversary and then we try to
rule them out so if you think that
statistical parity will take care of
your of your of an advertiser who
doesn't wish to advertise the steakhouse
to members of the minority group well we
can have them advertise proportionately
to both groups but among the minorities
they send the ads to the vegetarians
people who would not be interested in
the service so clearly it's
discriminatory but it satisfies this
sort of demographic parity constraint
for the the lone example you might have
very distribution very different
distributions of how you allocate the
loans for the people who are above
threshold so for example you may choose
to to to give the loans to the
assimilationists to the people who look
as much like the majority as possible
and meet these statistical requirements
so I'm just saying that these broad
brushes are not are not expressive
enough and then you have other questions
which groups do you want to consider and
you necessarily you shouldn't
necessarily be relying on the members of
an oppressed group to notice even
necessarily that their treatment is
unfair they have to realize that their
visits work by mahzarin banaji managing
and I'm sorry I forgot the collaborator
which talks about how how oppressed
groups take in adopt the beliefs of the
oppressing group so we don't want to
have to force everybody always to be
standing up for themselves and what
about the intersectional case how do you
define the problem for the
intersectional case there are a lot of
intersections but also it's not even
clear what does affirmative action me
in the intersectional case we can come
up with examples where it's not clear
what you want to do even if you have a
general notion of what affirmative
action should be sorry that was my next
bullet okay and another thing is that
these these these statistical
requirements are surprisingly hard to
test or surprisingly hard to test
meaningfully and an example of a paper
about this a very recent work by Neil
and Winship who argued that standard
benchmark and outcomes tests typically
produce invalid inferences that in their
words may diverge from reality in either
direction indicating discrimination when
it is not present or alternatively
indicating a lack of discrimination when
it is present so
just to emphasize it's it's not even
clear what the statistical conditions
mean when they are satisfied or when
they are not satisfied so this is why I
say very reductively group notions fall
under scrutiny so this led us to suggest
a long time ago individual fairness so
individual fairness says roughly
speaking that people who are similar
with respect to a given classification
task should be treated similarly by
classifiers for that task so if we're
trying to classify people in terms of
whether we should send them an
advertisement about a book a certain
kind of book well people who have
similar interests perhaps reading
interests should be treated similarly
hair products could be a completely
different story so people who are
similar with respect to their reading
interests may be wildly different with
respect to their hair products and
there's no reason for an advertiser
who's going to be advertising a hair
product to treat people with similar
reading interests
similarly okay so and and and while some
legal scholars think that group
conditions are meaningful under certain
circumstances there seems to be a more
pervasive notion in law that similarly
situated people should be treated
similarly so this framework is very
powerful but it requires that metric
that notion of how similar a pair of
people is every pair of people perhaps
is for the given classification task and
we don't know where do we get that
metric from and so that sort of brought
that line of research a little bit to a
halt so individual fairness requires a
task specific metric on the other hand
very recent work by my student Christina
L Vento shows how given access to a fair
adjudicator or an arbiter and that could
be a human or it could be some
incredibly carefully trained device you
can with
a surprisingly small number of queries
to this to this arbiter get a good
approximation to the metric or okay now
the the notion of similarly treated
people similar people being treated
similarly is it's very appealing
intuitively and it also doesn't require
the similarity metric to actually make
any value judgments about individuals it
doesn't have to say how exactly how
qualified somebody is just it just has
to understand something about how
similar they are and so that that can be
useful for allowing this metric not to
sort of force certain behaviors on
algorithms that may have different tasks
but need the same similarity information
and in particular it allows us to avoid
having to under to create scores that is
the fairness part doesn't have to create
scores now let's talk about risk scores
so scoring functions these assign scores
to people but they often those scores
are often interpreted as probabilities
so in fact you can rescale the scores so
that the individuals are always given a
score between zero and one and people
tend to treat these as probabilities so
what's the probability that it's going
to rain tomorrow a 30% chance of rain
18% 20% chance of rain you're used to
seeing things like that and that's you
could think of that as a scoring
function that maybe takes into account
the weather today and yesterday and
maybe what it was like last year or
typically at this time of year what's
coming on the jet stream across the
Pacific and so on and make a prediction
or for a given person P what's the
probability that P will repay alone do
you get a number between 0 and 1
probability when we have a tumor what's
the probability if we follow a
particular medical course of treatment
that this tumor will metastasize and of
course very poignant Lee what is the
probability that this individual will
commit a violent crime and this is a
predictor that is used in trying to
decide whether you should keep someone
in jail or let them out on parole so
what's the probability though of a non
repeatable event so if you're a
cryptographer you say okay there's some
let's say in the lone case ok people
have some internal randomness they
interact with the environment the by
environment has its own randomness and
the probability space is over the joint
probability distribution of these the
random coins of the individual in the
environment but outside the filter
bubble of cryptography you don't really
have people necessarily believing in
these things is there randomness and
whether it's going to rain tomorrow or
we just can't quite figure out whether
it's going to rain is there randomness
inside the tumour and the way the tumor
interacts with the body or do we just
not under the the capacity to take in
all of the information and compute from
it and of course is there randomness and
whether this person is going to commit a
violent act in the next couple of years
or is is everything already determined
what is the meaning you can't give a
loan and then see what happens and then
rewind and give a loan again and see
what happens and say yes in 30% of these
lifetimes this person retained so what
is the meaning of probability in these
cases so just to like get you a little
bit of intuition
let's think about the tumeric example so
we have this tumor the tumor it has
let's say certain genomic markers on it
so maybe we have a study where we look
at a bunch of tumors that have those
markers and we say in 70 percent of the
cases there was metastases so okay so
maybe that may be what the doctor says
here is yeah it's 70 percent but what if
there's another study that may even look
at other features and it turns out that
your tumor has these other features and
of a study that only looked at those
other features forty percent
metastasized so what's now you're
thinking about the probability that this
tumor is going to metastasize is it
lower than seventy percent do you say oh
wow there are there are bad markers of
two kinds is a bigger than 70 percent
you know what do we make of it and maybe
the picture looks like this so no
further information about your
particular tumor but of the seven of the
ones that were in the original if you
look at a set of other features that
yours doesn't have but that intersects
some of the other tumors that are in
this study maybe 40 percent of those
does that increase no the probability
creases the probability over here so did
your did your probability just go wrong
so one of the things that's going on in
machine learning if there's like this
balancing between all of these different
kinds of statistical inputs and you're
getting a sort of reconciliation and
there are many possible reconciliations
of these various statistical inputs so
the question about what does individual
risk mean is not new at all here's a
recent survey that was done by Phillip
David who's been studying these things
since the early 80s at least
and what does he say he says we survey a
variety of possible explanations of the
term individual risk these in turn are
based on a variety of interpretations of
probability including classical and new
merchant frequency formal metaphysical
personal propensity chance and logical
conceptions of probability and he ends
up concluding that the concept remains
subtle and modestly says that he has
some pragmatic suggestions for moving
forward so what do I think I think that
this is basically the defining problem
of scoring in artificial intelligence
and we heard earlier that we were
supposed to use big terms in our right
so this is the defining problem of the
AI era what does a probability what does
an individual probability mean so I'm
not going to say a lot about this but
and as I said this is work in progress
but we're exploring a different take a
different approach to it not in the
statistics literature that has its roots
in complexity theory and at a very high
level and I think I do have time for one
more slide so at a very high level which
I'll say tiny bit more about its it
works but we're thinking in terms of an
analogy to pseudo randomness or
indistinguishability and if this general
approach is wildly successful which is
an enormous if first of all the method
will explicitly tie what we give as the
stated meaning of the individual
probability to the limitations of the
features and training data that are used
in building the scoring function so what
I something I'm meant to mention when we
had this example with the tumor were the
seventy percent and the forty percent
this is incredibly important point that
what you measure matters and we've heard
this
over and over again we heard about this
in the context of the child the
Allegheny County algorithm for screening
calls for abuse and child abuse and
neglect that the information that's
available about a poor child and a poor
family is vastly greater than the
information that's available about a
wealthy family that has access to
private insurance for example and
private drug rehabilitation programs so
we see just immediately even in that
simple example how the choice of
features matters enormously so what we
we need to do is explicitly state this
connection of the limitations of the
features and the training data that are
used in building the function and also
it will provide some explicit tests for
the inadequacy of this pair of features
collected that can combined with the
training data combination so the
starting point for this work is what's
an effort to bridge this gap between
group based definitions and individual
based definitions and it's multi
calibration work by a bear Johnson Kim
Ryan Gauld and Roth Blum and what they
did was they looked at a very large
collection of sets remember I said which
sets are we going to consider they
looked at a really large collection of
sets in fact sets that were defined by a
computation class not special judgments
about should we include people who like
to wear frilly dresses as a category but
rather anything that could be
expressible with a very simple
computation let's say given the data
that you have that's how you were
defining the classes and they create
they show that they can ensure something
called calibration and which I'll
describe in a second
on each of the sets in these collections
simultaneously so calibration is sort of
the cynic when on of four
casting it says for example if you look
at all of the days on which the
forecaster predicted the night before
30% chance of rain then indeed on 30% of
those it should have rained
that's calibration and and
simultaneously all of the days on which
the forecaster predicted 70% chance of
rain if you look at all of those indeed
it rained on 70% of those so what they
are insuring is calibration
simultaneously on all of these sets now
this does not adjust in any way for past
injustice --is and and so this is part
of a framework of trying to fully fully
understand and respect your data and
then in a separate phase figure out how
to adjust for inequities but at least
properly and accurately give range to
the full expression of what's actually
being rendered for you and then after
that we worked on evidence based you
know sort with that as a starting point
we looked at evidence based ranking with
three of the original authors and
Galliano and which defines and avoids
certain kinds of ranking evils so as I
said to evelyn yesterday we write a in
response Evelyn's question we make a
list of evils that we want to rule out
and we make sure that what we build does
in fact rule them out and so that's
that's what we were doing and it was in
the course of that that we came across
something that we believe will yield
well it does yield a one-sided and
inefficient for now test for inadequacy
of the data so it's not a two-way test
and it's not something you could
actually compute right now but
information theoretically we can get
somewhere and that's why this if we are
wildly successful this is what why we
are hoping in that direction
okay so these are people who were not
explicitly cited or whatever but their
work so that the ordering on the
pictures is essentially chronologically
in terms of appearance in the talk and
when there are ties sorted
alphabetically Jamie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay
so in the interest of this being the
last section of talks I suspect this
talk will be less than 20 minutes so
maybe that's good maybe that's bad but I
I feel like we've had a lot of a lot of
presentations this week so so the thing
I want to talk to you today about sort
of stems from this idea that in general
when we see machine learning systems
acting in a way that we don't expect
usually the answer or the the reason
that people give is that we don't
fundamentally understand how any
particular machine learning system works
why any particular machine learning
system makes any particular prediction
for a specific case and that is
primarily problematic and the reason
that many of us are interested in that
is that there is mounting evidence that
the systems we have built in the
ecosystems in which they exist with the
historical inequities which exist in
society do not seem to be doing an
equally good job predicting outcomes for
different types of people right types
being very poorly defined
and the thing I want to mention is that
we don't totally understand why this is
the case right in many cases I mean
there are specific cases which if you
investigate carefully you might be able
to say something about why this is
happening but in general I think we are
woefully in unable to say is this
primarily the case because we have
chosen a specific algorithm that has
some problem perhaps you know this is
sort of the cop-out answer from my
perspective but like you know is this
the case because you know no matter how
we were trying to do this prediction
using a machine using a human if we are
trying to do this kind of prediction
perhaps it's inevitable that you know
we'll have sort of inherently different
accuracy rates for different populations
is this primarily a statistical problem
that we have more or less information
from a sort of sample complexities since
about one population versus another and
the thing I want to say is that in
general if we're talking about this
field broadly speaking and this set of
phenomena broadly speaking we don't
fully understand when and why or when we
would expect to see this sort of
behavior and I'm saying that as a
computer scientist so I have like
epsilon more understanding about how
like machine learning systems work than
the general population member of the
general population although I guess I
can't reverse time and think about
anyway so sorry so I feel like I've said
this in front of a number of you in the
last couple of days but this is
regularly brought up and I think most
I'm saying this provocatively I don't
think that people in this community
generally believe this but I think
people regularly ask well isn't this
just a policy question are there not
technical answers or meaning technically
meaty questions to answer in this space
right isn't this just like someone needs
to write a law or write some policy
about like the way our algorithm should
behave and then we can satis
that sort of post-hoc right and I guess
the the point I want to make is that and
people have been making throughout the
the workshop is that the most effective
way to ensure our systems work well pull
up and then you know analogously work
well for a broad range of different
populations is that we should be
thinking about how the systems treat a
diverse set of people throughout the
design process right and that includes
thinking about it from a computational
lens and I think when we're thinking
about very standard computational tools
that we use in all sorts of different
domains thinking about when they may be
inadvertently increasing some of the
problems we're seeing or introducing
some of the problems that we're seeing
that can maybe help us start to look at
some of the things we might be doing
inadvertently to be worsening the milieu
of problems that society and every other
part of the pipeline might be
introducing okay so you know I'm just
sort of hammering this home not all
mistakes are created equal
and you know even if you're if I'm just
trying to convince you you being some of
the young computer scientists who
haven't decided if this is a space that
you're interested in working in I became
a scientist because I care about
changing the world right and I think a
lot of people who call themselves
scientists want to change the world
don't we want to understand that we
understand how we're changing the world
I personally would really like that and
also if we want not a rejection of the
systems we build and you know revolts
against large scale machine learning
systems that we build I think it's
really critical that we get this right
so the question that I want to think
about slightly more precisely is when
and why machine learning algorithms
treat different demographic groups
differently and I know that's bill
defined but and whether or not it's
possible to make them robust to moderate
demographic differences okay so I made
this this morning and I apologize for
for cribbing from Zack so I wanted to
draw this very generic model of what
machine learning looks like
in general the thought is I have a bunch
of samples I feed them to some algorithm
which gives me a model which can then
label new samples right and this is a
pretty standard way of thinking about
supervised machine learning right
most people who who are giving examples
of what machine learning does are
talking about supervised learning right
and just as we were discussing in the
last section this scoping is super super
super narrow right so like this is not I
mean this is the simplest mathematical
formulation of what machine learning
does and is but it is far from a
complete picture and probably I actually
I somewhat disagree that this is like
the most common use of machine learning
I actually think when talking to people
in industry unsupervised tasks are like
super super common clustering
dimensionality reduction which we'll
talk about in a moment all sorts of
things where there's not a clear
prediction task which is at hand but
like trying to understand some latent
structure about some big data set and
then maybe doing something or as a
result of that is the far more common
case in a lot of these online
applications that people think about so
I want to zoom out just a bit and
recognize that this view of machine
learning really ignores even just from
the machine learning perspective not
many parts of the pipeline that like
machine learning experts develop not
that policymakers develop and not the
historical inequities sort of imbibe
into the system okay so the thing I want
to briefly talk about today
is what's called high dimensional data
mining okay so how many people if I say
dimensionality reduction how many people
in the room know what that is okay so
that's more or less consistent with what
I thought okay good
consistent in that every machine every
every computer scientist that I
recognized raise their hand okay
and I don't think any of the non
computer scientists that I knew raise
their hands and I apologize for those of
you who I don't know okay yeah yeah yeah
okay but but actually Joan you're
getting a call out because you mentioned
the precise form of dimensionality
reduction that I'm going to talk a
little bit about in your talk and you
made two points that I think are super
critical one of which is like people
regularly run PCA before doing anything
else which you know when I say what this
means in a minute like that that's
important I think the point is that in
lots of healthcare and medical
applications there's some pre-processing
that happens well before the picture I
had on the previous slide that happens
without thinking okay and the second
point she made was that differences
inside of a group are often much greater
than differences between different
groups okay
so if you're thinking about that
geometrically right the space of people
who belong to one demographic group is
often much broader in all the directions
then like the space if you're imagining
these groups being destroyed the space
between two different groups if that
geometric interpretation is helpful okay
so I'll tell you what high dimensional
data mining is okay so in general a data
set you know in a very abstract sense
it's just thought of as like a bunch of
examples right we can think of them as
representations of patients or people
and then a whole bunch of pieces of
information that I have about those
individuals right and I'm trying to make
this a very imagine having you know
10,000 people but many men
many more pieces of information about
them okay so maybe we haven't yet
abolished population genetics and I have
like every an indicator vector for every
single gene in the human genome and
we're trying to from that you know we we
have this high dimensional data set
we're sort of interested in like what we
can learn from it and we're not trying
to like do some prediction tasks we just
have a huge huge huge data set and we
want to know something about it okay so
a pretty standard first thing to do
first being some caveat is to come up
with something so the important point
about this is that there's a skinny
matrix and a narrow matrix right so to
come up with something which is much
smaller right like this times this it
doesn't look so on this on this on this
particular slide but the amount of space
necessary to write down M this original
data set and just like one row of
numbers and another row of numbers is
you know this is going to take up way
way way less space okay so like take a
huge data set that lives in really high
dimensional space and find a really low
dimensional representation of that data
okay so there are many reasons to do
this but this is a pretty standard
pre-processing tech technique for all
sorts of different application domains
okay and these are usually called low
dimensional representations and the
reason people often want to do this
there are mostly technical reasons
although the first one which I think is
really critical is that people often
like low dimensional representations of
their otherwise ginormous data sets
because humans are super bad at thinking
about anything beyond like three
dimensions right we can visualize three
dimensions and if you like try to
visualize what like a 20 dimensional
space is we don't our eyes
live in well I don't know how you count
dimensions but like three depth
dimensions okay so if you don't want to
visualize the data set that lives in
10000 dimensions it's very helpful to
map it on to three dimensions okay
for that reason when people are trying
to understand if there's some meaningful
trend in a data set that they're looking
at and they don't know what they're
looking for and they just want to
literally look at it one thing that's
common is to project down into a very
small maybe one or two dimensions and
try to understand what they see there
right
this is also useful for the reason I
mentioned before write a data set takes
much less space up if you only write
down ten numbers about it than 10,000
and also it gets rid of some nasty
statistical questions some statistical
problems that you might have if you
don't do this okay so okay so I think
this is really really common and and you
know I I did appreciate that Joan like
specifically called out a certain kind
of low dimensional representation
finding in her talk that she sort of
took for granted right PCA that if
that's a word that is something you know
but it's very common to use some kind of
low dimensional representation of a high
dimensional data set as pre-processing
when doing all sorts of things with the
data set and I think it's important that
we think about that choice but the one
takeaway is I think we should to think
about every choice but this choice is
perhaps a problematic choice if your
data set actually does represent a bunch
of people who for example may be male
and female okay the reason being if I
take a data set that lives in 10000
dimensions and I write it down in 10
dimensions one of the things I said was
that saves a bunch of space right it's
like I can write it on a much smaller
harddrive than if I was writing down
every single number
but in so doing if I'm taking up less
space I necessarily have less
information about the people in that
data set right or at least conceivably I
have right I can write more things down
on a big hard drive than us than a thumb
drive
and the question is that I would like to
ask is whether when I do that projection
into a much smaller space saving
representation do I lose more
information about one of my populations
than another and I think this is again
sorry to call Jonah out again critically
important because lots of the ways
people tend to represent datasets in
lower dimensions care about sort of how
much difference there is between the
points in the data set in the lower
dimensional representation and if
there's much more difference between
different women than there are between
women and men this could be hugely
problematic right if we if we do in fact
lose much more information about one
subgroup than another okay so I just
want to say so so one such technique for
this is PCA and if you run PCA on a
pretty standard data set right so a
vision data set that has a whole bunch
of images of famous beautiful people
if you run PCA on it in general what we
found was that you have roughly 10%
higher reconstruction error on male
faces other direction female faces than
male faces I've given this talk before I
can't believe I didn't okay so so what
this means is if you have some high
dimensional data set like images and you
project images of faces you project that
down onto say three or five dimensions
you've already lost some more
information about one of these groups
than another and that could be pretty
problematic right if we're thinking
about this is like a pre-processing step
before we find like interesting patterns
upon which we do like medical studies
right so
it's also the case that like one one
solution to this is okay if you have a
bunch of data some of which belongs to
men belong still like a male population
and some of which belongs to a female
population maybe the right thing to do
is just treat them totally separately
right and there are a variety of cases
in which you might want to do that right
if you're looking at certain kinds of
things that you do believe there's you
know if you have a specific task in mind
that may be appropriate but there are
other cases in which you wouldn't want
to do that right it may be the case that
you have a huge amount of additional
demographic information on this sort of
data set you're doing exploratory data
analysis on but then you're going to
like do a whole bunch of other things
and then later down the line you'll have
a lot of that information remaining but
you don't have the demographic
information right you maybe don't have
whether certain patients or male and
female at some point down the line when
you're also trying to use the same
projection okay
so you know that a simple solution in
general is to do everything separately
and just like let the entire pipelines
be separate for like all of our
different groups but there are lots of
reasons you might not want to do that
okay so this is totally unreadable okay
so that's alright um this is a pretty
picture on my anyway so this is just
saying we have like representations of
the datasets restricted to men and women
and we're sort of thinking of those in
high dimensional space and the primary
takeaway from this work from a technical
perspective not from sort of a more
meaningful societal one is that it's
possible to find these low like low
dimensional representations of datasets
in a computational sense that are doing
sort of as well as you could hope for
both groups simultaneously okay so we're
going to lose some information about
both populations but we're going to be
able in a computational sense to lose
the same amount of information right
which wouldn't happen for free just
doing standard standard things right so
you don't need to parse this but that's
what this is saying
Cynthia it looked like you have a
question yeah okay okay
okay so that's the last technical slide
and I write in some recent paper on
reconstruction as a privacy measure and
then they show that if you are if you
had very long tires on the data and you
intervention price with a big error
parameter I mean allowing a lot of lost
price you cannot be constructive as long
as there is no fires so in other words
this thing or is busy information you
know if you lose more information you
get more privacy some condition on the
fire right
I don't know precisely the the paper
you're talking about but I'd be
interested to hear more about it yeah
okay
so I just want to have this as the
takeaway slide right I think it's really
important that we think about why our
machine learning methods do treat
different demographic groups so
differently and to try to make them as
robust as possible which often means
thinking beyond just like the supervised
learning like are we doing sort of
similarly in terms of prediction rates
for this very specific prediction tasks
for different demographic groups and
this really requires thinking about some
how there is supposed to be another that
we're supposed to we really need to
think about the entire process by which
we are coming to our scientific
conclusions machine learning and
otherwise not just thinking about
supervised learning
[Music]
[Applause]
bonus slide
our next speaker is Dwayne up full Wiley